let's do review the reviewers we haven't
done that in a while it's where i
sort of comb through the sometimes
blisteringly positive reviews on apple
podcasts and find some that are worth it
i do like to know what the people are
thinking i don't want anyone no you
don't i do actually i have people
approach me on the street all the time
and talk to me about the podcast and i
do enjoy that but this is a chance for
me to get outside my little bubble uh
and and find out
how people really feel well this one is
kind of carrying on a theme that i'm
starting to notice or a pattern and i
think we might want to address it this
is similar to one we've had before the
subject is conan cool it's five stars
and it's written by
igdet and it goes like this conan and
the chill chumps are cool exclamation
mark by the way i'm 11 and i listen
slash watch you
exclamation mark that's like the third
10 or 11 year old we've had lever
reviews saying they listen to this show
i want to say that that fills my heart
with glee
because i've always thought
that my target audience was about 11.
and i
i think that this is proof that uh
that i'm correct
my whole career i've always thought
there are children out there who
completely understand what i'm doing and
yeah
you know for years in my monologue i'd
have jokes and some were better than
others but then i started just playing
peek-a-boo with the camera i would tell
the i would tell the cameraman to lock
off the camera and and early on the
cameraman would follow me if i walked to
the right of the left and i would tell
them don't lock it off don't move it
i'll walk out of camera and then i'll
peek back in and i would see
you know 350 people in the audience all
adults laughing really hard when i
peeked back in and i realized that we're
all 11 year olds
we're smaller we're we're six year olds
we're five-year-olds the fact that i
by p but leaving the frame and then
peeking back in would make people giggle
and i thought i think inside all of us
or most of us there is that little kid
and so the fact now that actual children
are writing in and saying this
uh show matches my intellectual and
emotional capacity perfectly that makes
me very happy
you know the show is very visual and
this is you
saying things so i i wonder what it is
about how you say things or what you say
that is appealing to
children
well that's a that's a very valid point
that's true i can understand why the
show i would act like a foolish man um
what is it now about hearing me
uh i don't i don't know i don't know if
any of you have any insights into why
uh right now i'm speaking you'd think
that that would not make an 11 year old
laugh or 10 year old but i think often
in my conversations um do funny voices i
think i do some funny voices but i think
maybe they can just tell
this man is stunted developmentally
yeah i think that comes across
i mean i think it doesn't matter who i'm
talking to we had an interview with uh
supreme court justice sotomayor not too
long ago and and
i did my best to be thoughtful and to
hold my own and discuss the great issues
of the day
but also i i showed uh terrible lapses
into foolishness and childishness with
some of my questions and um did you hear
that she got impeached just for being i
i i i i just
she did and even she didn't even fight
it that was the interesting thing they
they impeached
the first she introduced the article the
first is
the first time they've removed to
sitting justice and they brought it to
her and she said uh there's what can i
do i deserve to go
she did the podcast and then just went
back and started packing up yeah
it was instantly i think what she did is
she said i'm off to do conan's podcast
start packing while i'm gone career
suicide by podcast yeah and then uh she
said to one of the the the clerks uh and
that nice ceremonial gavel they gave me
this uh 200 years old that i got when i
began extreme court uh justice you
should just put that in the shredder
because um
i'm off to do conan o'brien's podcast so
our biggest response to her appearance
was from 10 and 11 year olds who said i
know how an 11 year old finds their way
to this podcast is it through their
parents or on their own well
we do
i've tried to get lots of tie-ins with
children's products
so yeah
so there's a lot of toys out there if
you go to any toy store and i know they
don't exist anymore it's all online so
don't get me there
but um most toys now show up
um
with a picture of me somewhere on the
box that says as discussed on conan's on
uncle conan's podcast and these are
these yeah these are toys for like three
and four-year-olds they say
um be careful
uh you know don't don't leave unattended
with you know this
block
yeah no no no no
please don't go down that road um no i
uh i'm doing all i'm doing what i can to
make sure that i get a lot of tie-ins i
do a lot of nickelodeon appearances
um yeah my dermatologist have you been
slimed i've been slimed so many times my
dermatologist said that it's eating into
my bone they found green slime in my
marrow
so i've got to stop that um i toured
with the wiggles for a while when they
were
making their new zealand tour i'm doing
everything i can to make sure that i get
to very young children so that they grow
up thinking conan o'brien is
the podcaster oh you're indoctrinating i
am indoctrinating them yes okay yeah
gotcha well then why did this kid call
us chumps yeah good question the hill
yeah kid he loves me he thinks you guys
are extraneous i think it's because he
can tell both of you
occasionally laps into
uh sober thought and reflection
and he knows that i'm the one that will
never let him down the 24-hour clown
i just wanted the ending to rhyme
and i did yeah peace out eight-year-olds
mike dropped
yes mike
nope we picked it back up i grabbed the
mic and i dropped it mic drop i put a
little net above the floor cutting that
now dropping mike mike falls through net
mike hits floor mic drop huge magnet on
ceiling raises
machine i have built by scientist
reverses polarity of your magnet fires
mike into ground it sticks to ground mic
i'm involved in a nuclear accident in
the 1950s and control the gravitational
matter in the earth's core i travel
further back in time than you do i shoot
you when you're 15 years old i make sure
that you cannot reverse the polarity mic
drop mike can never be picked up again
you don't exist killed by me when you're
15.
my ultimate plan comes true now i don't
have to do this podcast
[Laughter]